(audience applauding)
We've got
an incredible guest at the desk.
She is a golden globe nominee
for her work in the hit, musical series
Zoey's Extraordinary Playlist,
(audience cheering)
and just in time for the holiday season,
the whole cast is back for an encore,
in the brand new, TV movie,
Zoey's Extraordinary Christmas!
Take a look!
You're reading my mind right now, aren't you?
You're reading mine
and you definitely don't want to do something
just the two of us!
It's all,
it's all really nice, Max, truly.
It's just.
What?
I don't want to not think about my dad
and be apart from my family for the holidays.
It's not the course. It doesn't feel right.
I want us all to be together
and have the most amazing Christmas ever!
Oh my goodness!
Please welcome,
Zoey herself,
Jane Levy!
(audience applauding)
Hi!
Oh my god!
I am so happy to meet you.
I'm so excited to see you.
I am so happy to be here.
I'm such a big fan of both of you.
Aw!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Thank you for coming in,
gracing us with your presence,
and bringing holiday cheer.
Okay. So, Zoey's Extraordinary Playlist,
mega hit,
golden globe nominations.
(audience applauding)
I love it.
Loved the show.
Critical acclaim.
It stops on NBC,
and then you guys get together
for this wonderful closure.
I almost think that maybe this isn't closure,
like, maybe this is a thing
that can go on and on and on.
You heard it here!
(man chuckling)
And we're starting first with Christmas.
Yeah!
Well, this is all because of the fans.
They were so enthusiastic
and unwavering in their support for this show.
And then Roku picked us up,
so thank you so much.
But I heard for this movie,
you only had like four days
to rehearse for all of the dancing?
That is correct.
How did you do it?
What?
We just did it.
(man laughing)
That's what we had,
and yeah, that's what we did.
So, you just drill it into your mind
and you're like,
we're going to get this.
Yeah.
How?
(woman stammering)
I guess that's why they call it extraordinary.
Yeah!
Yeah, yes.
(audience applauding)
Alright.
That's all it is.
Congratulations.
Jane, would you like to do some taglines with us?
Absolutely.
(woman squealing)
(woman laughing)
Good!
Okay, well Jane, it is your story.
All right,
I've got a very hot topic.
Okay.
And that is re-gifting.
(man chuckling)
So, Real Simple says,
there's no shame in the re-gifting game.
Just because a gift isn't right for you
doesn't mean it's not perfect for somebody else.
They even suggest keeping a special drawer
of re-giftables all year long
so you can match them with the perfect person later,
and 'tis the season to be sustainable.
And this stuff saves stuff from the landfill.
There's no shame in re gifting.
You know many people have given me a candle?
Thank you so much. But,
(audience laughing)
I'm just one man.
So, you know,
(woman laughing)
we've said, it's somebody's birthday,
or the holidays, or something,
and we run into someone actually,
someone pops over,
oh, just for you!
But, the problem with the gifting
is you do have to sell the backstory.
Right?
And like, I tend to oversell it.
Like I panic.
Like, oh,
I was at the mall,
and I saw it,
and it was pink,
and I know you love pink,
and so I was like,
oh, I'm gonna get it for Drew,
and anyway, I hope you love it!
So you're a re-gifter and a fibber!
Totally will lie to your face.
(woman laughing)
Oh my god!
Jane, how do you feel about re-gifting?
If someone gives me a gift that I maybe won't use,
'cause maybe I already have a set of headphones,
or something,
I think give it to somebody,
but not as their birthday present.
Be like, I was gifted this.
It's just a random Tuesday,
and I can't use this,
and I love you, so take this.
But I think if it's like,
this is your grand, Christmas present.
I probably wouldn't re-gift in that way.
Okay, now,
then I'm more with you
because I do,
if I get something that,
(woman laughing)
we're not ganging up against you, Rossi.
I'm feeling a little judged.
I have to say.
(women laughing)
Just a scoche!
All right.
And finally,
we're celebrating Hanukkah in today's Food News!
(audience applauding)
Hey, Food News!
Now, Jane,
my daughters are half Jewish
and we celebrate Hanukkah and Christmas.
Is it true that you grew up the same way?
I did, yeah.
And if only you knew that
what we're about to eat is my favorite food.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Okay, well,
In The Know reports that
the latest remix on the latke
is the fried pickle latke.
Okay!
I mean,
you had me at latke,
and now you have me even deeper with pickle.
It's a traditional latke,
stuffed with a dill pickle.
Mhm!
(audience giggling)
Okay!
This is my definition of heaven.
Oh my god.
This is a whole, latke flavor.
(audience laughing)
That pickle is next level.
It gives it a saltiness. A brininess.
A tang.
Yeah.
Like a salty, starch
in a creamy salt,
is just what I want to eat at all times.
Oh my god!
It's interesting.
How come pickles and potatoes
are not like the hot new couple?
Why are they not a thing?
Can I ask you guys a question?
Since Zoey's Extraordinary Christmas is coming up,
can each one of us recommend a holiday movie?
Oh, I love that!
I was more into spooky season,
so like The Nightmare Before Christmas was more my vibe.
That's perfect!
Okay.
Okay,
Ross, what about you?
What's your recommendation?
This Christmas,
I'm making myself watch holiday classics
I'd never seen before.
Like, Miracle On 34th Street,
I've never seen it.
It's A Wonderful Life. I've never seen it.
What?
I know.
I know!
What?
(audience laughing)
I said, I'm doing the work, okay?
My uncle,
Lionel Barrymore, is Potter in the wheelchair.
Okay!
(audience applauding)
I will know that right when I watch it.
My great uncle,
Lionel, is the villain!
He's the bad man in It's A Wonderful Life.
And he was in a wheelchair in real life.
Fun fact.
Wow.
Well, maybe not a fun fact.
But, I get it.
Well, when I watch it,
I'll be like, oh, hey uncle!
Okay?
(audience laughing)
But I think my favorite is A Christmas Story.
The one that airs on TV all day long on Christmas day.
It's a classic.
(audience applauding)
And it makes me feel like it's Christmas.
I'm gonna go with Planes, Trains, and Automobiles.
Oh!
(audience applauding)
Wow!
Every year.
Really?
All the time.
I love it so much. It's the greatest.
Jane Levy, I'm so glad that you came to eat latkes
and talk Hanukkah, and Christmas,
and Zoey's Extraordinary Playlist,
and Zoey's Extraordinary Christmas,
and we can't wait to continue to celebrate y'all.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Thank you for being here.
Zoey's Extraordinary Christmas
on the Roku channel,
December 1st!
All the fans are gonna be lining up!
(upbeat instrumental music)